steve what what are we looking at today
though
well i'm slightly concerned by what i'm
looking at because you seem to be in a
different location have you expanded is
there something odd going on and you're
stroking something like a bond villain
there yeah
i'm puppy sitting so this is marley
hello hello marley say hello to everyone
there we go that's marley marley is a
ship and unfortunately i can't leave him
alone for very long because he's quite
young
so he's probably going to eat the
microphone and everything but it means
that i'm having to do this on wi-fi well
that's great because i wanted to talk
about wi-fi we briefly touched on this
when we talked about the wi-fi hidden no
problem where you've got the access
point and then you've got the two
computers that are sufficiently far away
from it that they can't talk to each
other they can't see each other's
transmissions but they can both talk to
the access point and we talked about how
the access point could configure things
by sending the sort of clear to send
packets out to enable them to
communicate without
colliding with each other when both
machines tried to transmit at the same
time and i thought we could talk about a
few more issues that sort of come up
from using wireless networks that you
perhaps don't get in the same way if
you've got a cable between all the
machines in particular this is the
fascinating sort of relationship between
your sort of wi-fi speed
distance
and time
when we have a wi-fi network we we know
the basics we have an access point which
is connected to our internet connection
via ethernet usually technically doesn't
have to be but that's what we tend to
use these days and then it transmits via
radio waves either 2.4 gigahertz or 5
gigahertz or a few variations but we
won't get into that we'll keep things
generic in this video
it transmits the data to your machine
and
we sort of know intuitively from
basically having used it that if we are
sitting close to the wi-fi access point
then generally we'll get a good
connection the speeds are high but and i
think you've experienced this short
if you get far enough away from the
access point well the speed tends to
drop off until you get further enough
away you don't get
any speed at all and you just lose
connection so i thought we could talk
about why wi-fi networks have to do that
and some of the implications that become
because of the way they're managing it
now why does the speed have to drop off
well i think an easy way to look at it
and to make things slightly tricky for
sure when he's editing this video seeing
as he's remote and i'm remote is i've
got um my ipad here
and we can see the problem visually i
put some text
on the screen of the ipad and hopefully
you can see this if not sean's got some
superimposition to do um but it's uh can
you see what it says here sean
it's just bleached out on the skype i'm
afraid it's all completely white as far
as i can sort of bring the brightness
down
oh yeah just sort of
yeah i can see this text but it's a bit
blurry so you can see this text is a bit
blue now one way i could get that better
for you is to
bring it closer and if i bring it closer
to the camera eventually it's still
gonna be blurry because i'm not
refocusing the camera i can see words
bit more clearly but i can't see what
they say let me just make the text um
bigger
okay um so we're going to do the same
thing i'm going to make the text
right yeah we got it now hello world
hello world yeah and things and in fact
if i was to come back
to my um
thing here
if i made the text sufficiently big back
from where i originally started i
increased the size eventually standing
over here
you'd be able to see yeah i mean
notwithstanding the odd reflection i can
see hello world now we can work that out
yeah yeah exactly
and in many ways that's what's going on
with a wi-fi network
when i was far away and the text was
small that's equivalent to us
transmitting the data very very fast if
you were standing where i was you could
read that text fine but you couldn't
because i was far away from the camera
and the camera and the skype connection
was sort of reducing the quality of the
image and it's the same sort of thing
that's happening with wi-fi we know that
the wi-fi is transmitted over radio
signals and to do that it needs to
encode the zeros and ones that make up
the data packets the ethernet frames
that are being transmitted
into the radio waves we'll gloss over
how that's done we'll just keep it
general for this video i'm sure we can
do another video or someone can do a
video on all the encoding that's done
for that that's not my area of expertise
uh and things um but we take the data
and we encode it into a radio signal
that's transmitted and if we're
transmitting the data very very fast and
we do that by making each symbol of that
message well that's a zero and one and
again i'm glossing over how that's
encoded each symbol relatively short
amount of time it's a bit like when we
had the small text visually
so the the bits of the stems of the
characters were small
so we made them take up a small amount
of time as we transmit it now that's
fine if you're sitting underneath your
wi-fi access point you'll receive the
signal and your laptop or whatever it is
we'll be able to decode it and get the
original
zeros and ones that make up the frame
and process the data there's probably
some error correction going on in there
as well just to be able to sort of
correct things or at least error
checking to and so you know if the
packets got corrupted and you can ask
for it to be reset
so that's fine if you're there but as
you move away from your access point
then you're still going to get the
signal but as you move further away from
it the signal level is going to drop
just because of the way that radio waves
work further away you are from the
source the less powering kit
but also
it's not a perfect
environment you've got noise
in the radio spectrum anyway from
various sources other wi-fi networks
nearby or far away just general
background radio noise if you've got an
old fm radio and you tune it to an area
where there's no station you can hear
the static that's just the noise
of
the signal that's there so you've got
the signal which you're transmitting
which is getting less and less in power
as you move further away but you've also
got noise then that becomes a point
where
you can detect there is a signal just
like you could see that was something on
the ipad screen
but
you can't determine what it is because
it's sort of mixed in with the noise so
how do we get around that
well we do the same thing as i did with
the text
we make the symbols that make up
the message bigger
now we can't make them bigger physically
like we did the text but we can make
them
longer in time
and if we make them longer in time that
means it's going to take longer
for us to transmit
each symbol which means it's going to
take longer for the whole packet to
transmit
which means that the data that you're
receiving will come in slower
so a lot of the things that your wi-fi
access point in your laptop tablet phone
whatever it is you're using need to do
is negotiate a speed
so that when they transmit the data
it's transmitted at a speed that the
other end can receive it with enough
clarity there's still noise there just
as you saw that the text was still
wasn't perfectly crisp but it was
sufficiently clear enough amongst the
noise which we simulated with the camera
and things that you could actually get
the message and it's the same thing that
you need to do
with wi-fi so if your access points here
and your three floors up in your studio
then you're going through all different
floors which are going to attenuate the
signal there's noise from other things
in there and eventually you find that
you get a really slow signal it's
actually quicker to pick up the usb
stick and walk around and deliver it by
hand than it is to transmit it over the
network connection on the other hand if
you're downstairs looking after your dog
in the lounge and the wi-fi access point
is probably somewhere in the same
vicinity you get a rather decent signal
and you can do things you can watch
netflix whatever it is you want to do
without any problems other streaming
providers are available like the bbc
iplayer amazon prime tc plus discovery
the speed in which we can transfer data
over wi-fi is inherently related to how
far we are
from the access point because
as we get further away we need to
transmit things
either
in a longer amount of time so that
they're clearer to the receiver because
it says oh this is slightly higher up
now for
two seconds strength time massively but
you get the idea so this is probably a
one or a zero
for two seconds whereas if it was just
sort of half a second again shrink time
to some speeds that these things work at
it would be much harder to see what was
actually was that just a bit of noise
that i got there or was actually the one
that was being transmitted you can't
tell on the other hand if it's a longer
higher level for longer
you can receive what the signal is
the other thing you could do of course
is boost the power up
but you don't really have that option if
using something like a laptop because
you've got a finite amount of power from
the battery and the access point
if it boosts the power too much is going
to flood the whole neighborhood with
your wi-fi signal or you could use a
better aerial but again the aerials are
built into
[Music]
the machine and so on you need to do
something which means you can receive
the signal
clearer
than you could before and the easiest
way for the access point in the laptop
to do that is to just reduce the
transmission speed make the symbols
longer in time
and then you can detect what they are
and receive the ethernet frame the data
packet with the data that you're
interested in
now there's an interesting implication
of this
because we also need to think about how
our computers know whether there's a
wi-fi network there
so when you open up your laptop sean and
you want to connect to a new wi-fi how
do you do it
um
you don't make the dog bark
[Laughter]
well if you go for a new one you
basically scan the area don't you you
do you click on whatever icon it is on
whatever operating system you're using
that you know see what networks are out
there so presumably they're announcing
themselves somehow are they yeah exactly
so
generally unless it's a hidden wi-fi
network what we do is we see a list of
all the wi-fi networks that we're
interested in and we just pick the one
that we want to connect to it'll then
ask us for some encryption details sort
of the pre-shared key or maybe some
authentication details so that we can
set up an encrypted session so the data
is not transmitted in the clear at least
hopefully
and things and then they can talk to
each other
but
the wi-fi access point it does that by
sending out what's called a beacon
package and this basically just
announces that the wi-fi network is
there and is one of these sent out for
every different wi-fi network that
exists so if your wi-fi access point is
broadcasting several different wi-fi
networks for different reasons like the
ones at the university are you've got
eduroam for general use you've got
specific ones for our robots
and things to connect to which have
slightly different setups on them then
it needs to send out a beacon packet for
each of what we call the ssids
that describe each of those networks and
so it'll send one out for rome it'll
send one out for the robot related one
and so on
but now think about it
it cannot send them out at the fastest
speed
because if it did and you're sitting
three flights of stairs up in your
studio
you wouldn't detect it and so you
wouldn't know the wi-fi network was
there
so
how do you think the wi-fi access point
gets around there
well assuming he's got a variant speed
yeah and so actually what the wi-fi
networks do
is when they send out that beaconing
packet they send it at the slowest
possible speed that they're set up to do
and that could potentially go as low as
one megabit per second
if you're really far away from a wi-fi
network then you send that at one
megabit per second does that mean that
you're actually seeing
um networks from far far away ones that
you probably wouldn't even really
realistically be able to use
potentially yeah i mean i remember
when i moved into my house for the first
time opening up my uh this is before i
put the wi-fi network in which i did
relatively quickly uh before things like
the bathroom but that's another story uh
i opened up the wi-fi tab on my mac and
it was basically the whole screen full
of wi-fi networks every sort of house in
the area you could see a different wi-fi
network you could tell which providers
are using based on the ssid still saying
bt virgin whatever what network provider
they were with and so on but you could
see all these different wi-fi's chances
are most of them you'd be so far away
from that even if you knew the
credentials you wouldn't get a good
signal but you could just about to take
the beacon packets and say ah this
network is out there now the other thing
is you can't just send these packets um
once you can't just have your access
point say hey here i am
because if it did that well it might get
corrupted on transmission
in which case you wouldn't get it and so
you want to know it was there or you
might turn your laptop on after the
access point is sent it's actually that
access point sends that beacon packet
out several times a second
in fact it sends it every 102.4
milliseconds
and things
now
put this together
we're sending out a packet
every 102.4 milliseconds
it has to be transmitted at the lowest
speed possible
and it will take up a certain amount of
time because it's got data that needs to
be in there sort of what network channel
which part of the 2.4 gigahertz spectrum
is it using what the ssid is various
other options and the machines need to
communicate and things so it's about
things about 300 bytes or so that these
packets are plus you've got preambles
and post ambles and frame check
sequences so you can
make sure that it says so it takes up
a certain amount of time
and as that's being transmitted of
course you can only transmit one packet
at any one time
so as that's being transmitted
you can't actually transmit anything
else on your wi-fi network
and this is why network operators who
provide wi-fi in public spaces
don't like people coming along and using
their phone on hotspot tethering when
you turn on hotspot tethering whether
it's an android phone or an iphone
whatever it is when we turn on the
hotspot mode on our phone this
effectively becomes
a wi-fi network it becomes a wi-fi
access point it's transmitting out
beacon packets and it's either going to
be on the same channel as one of your
access points and if you've got a
commercial set up so in a sports stadium
or train station or something
you're probably going to be using all
the channels anyway so the chances that
you're transmitting on the same channel
as one of their access points
is very very high it sends out its
beaconing packet and again it will
probably do it at the slowest speed
possible because unless you've tuned it
it'll do it about one megabit a second
and so suddenly you have
the access point
peaking packet
then you have your personal hotspot
beacon packet and then they're going to
be transmitted again in 102.4
milliseconds
and so actually it doesn't take many
personal hotspots or at rogue access
points around to actually drag the speed
of the wi-fi network down
to sort of being unusable i think it's
something like 15 extra hotspots it's
that sort of order
um if you not set them all up properly
you can sort of drag the wi-fi speed
down to absolutely terrible positions so
actually when you sort of see people
saying don't use personal hotspots here
they're not doing it because they want
you to use their wi-fi network well they
might because they get money from that
possibly but it actually really does
degrade the performance for everyone so
if you if you're trying to use a free
wi-fi and you realize it's really slow
so you pull your phone out to make a
hotspot instead you're actually becoming
part of the problem
yeah effectively yeah and it's not just
that even in your
home network if you're sitting uh with
your puppy um
having a squat a skype conversation here
then you've probably got pretty good
signal there but if you've got someone
upstairs working in the studio also on
the wi-fi network who's on a slower
network
they're actually going to slow down your
connection because their packets are
going to take longer in time
and while they're transmitting you can't
transmit at the same time on the same
frequency
ignoring sort of memo type stuff which
use different frequencies and so on but
the simple thing you can't transmit at
the same time until they're done
so if you were to sort of sort of do a
sort of round robin type transmission
you transmit a packet yours is very very
fast
then you have to wait for their packet
then you transmit a very small one then
you have to wait for there it's more and
you transmit another one wait for their
small one
you end up that most of the time
you're sitting there waiting to transmit
while the other person is transmitting
slowly they probably don't notice much
of a difference because your packets are
very very fast and very very small but
you suddenly find that your network
speed is tanked purely because someone
else
elsewhere in the building is on the same
network
transmitting at a much slower speed
yeah it's called psycaboo it's out it's
after doctor who isn't it right so it's
been a while since i've watched doctor
who but the idea is that doctor
who keeps showing people this blank
piece of paper and it's psychic paper
which means that they see some
identification that means something and
when that space what it's doing is it's
looking for extra areas where it can add
the nodes to build that graph up